the Gospel of Thomas is kind of just  that a gospel it is an account of Jesus  of Nazareth or Jesus Christ but it  differs pretty drastically from the  gospels that we know Jesus does not  bring Salvation through his death  instead when we read Thomas it becomes  clear that it is the very teachings of  Jesus and the following of those  teachings that will lead the person to  Salvation by gaining knowledge of his  true self  in one of the most famous sayings from  the gospel Jesus says quote if your  leaders say to you look the kingdom is  in heaven then the birds of heaven will  precede you if they say to you it is in  the sea then the fish will precede you  rather the kingdom is inside you and it  is outside you  when you know yourselves then you will  be known then you will understand that  you are the children of the living  father